bueno para mí emprender es una
experiencia que me enriquece muchísimo
en muchos ámbitos y uno de ellos es en
el ámbito comercial hoy quiero compartir
con vosotros bueno algunos aprendizajes
que he cometido aquí aprendido y
emprendiendo quiero compartir los 10
errores en el mundo de las ventas que yo
he cometido y cuando hablo con otras
personas creo que también los cometemos
de forma sistemática el primer problema
es poner foco en el producto cuando eres
emprendedor como tú has creado el
producto te enamora de tu producto
cuánto vas a vender tu producto y sólo
le cuentas al cliente cuáles son las
características cuáles son las ventajas
a cuál son las funcionales de tu
producto pero a nadie le interesa tu
producto tu producto suele interesa a ti
a tu madre quizá a algún amigo que
tengas por ahí que también le interesa
vale pero al cliente lo que le interesa
son sus problemas o si quieres que les
resuelva un problema de satisfaga una
necesidad no que le cuentes cuál es su
producto es el primer error que
cometemos todos los emprendedores y los
vendedores el segundo error es abordar
todo el mercado es decir como
emprendedor al final las ventas son el
oxígeno que nos permiten pues seguir
luchando por nuestros sueños
vendedor pues si no cumplen la cuota que
te marca la compañía o los objetivos
comerciales al final pone en peligro un
poco no tu puesto de trabajo puesto que
es lo que hacemos lo que hacemos es
disparar a todo lo que se mueve en vez
de identificar el mercado ver un
segmento al que tenemos que dirigir y en
base a tus capacidades a tus recursos
que tiene pues priorizar y a ese
segmento de mercado el tercer error es
no hacer los deberes
vale decir vamos a una reunión y no
sabemos ni la persona con la que nos
vamos a entrevistar no sabemos nada de
la compañía y seguramente los más
avanzados por eso si miran el linkedin
el perfil de la persona para que se van
a reunir miran en la web a qué se dedica
esa empresa pero realmente no entiende
ni cuál es el modelo de negocio al
cliente es decir cómo gana dinero tu
cliente ni entienden el sector en qué
posición competitiva se encuentra tu
cliente es si no entienden nada eso que
hace que cuando vas a un cliente le
empieza a contar pues tus productos
cuáles las características las ventajas
las funcionalidades y cuando sales de la
reunión no entiendes por qué te compras
evidentemente el cliente te va a decir
que sí que la encanta mucho que producto
muy bueno que lo hace genial pero al
final no te compras porque no te compra
porque no has personalizado el discurso
de los deberes
entiendes al cliente el cuarto error es
ponerte habla no decir el cliente cierra
una reunión te da un slow de una hora y
llegas allí empieza a soltarle tu rollo
que piensas que tienen una hora para
contar el tu rollo en vez de pararte
escuchar al cliente hacerle preguntas
inteligente para entender cuáles son sus
objetivos de negocios cuáles son sus
retos cuál es la problemática a la que
se enfrenta quién es quién entre la
organización es información que te va a
permitir hacer un diagnóstico para luego
personalizar la propuesta de valor
evidentemente si vas a venderle tu
producto o servicio pero intentando
conectar tu producto o servicio con las
necesidades los problemas que tiene tu
cliente y luego mostrarle en términos de
beneficios y en términos de impacto en
su negocio lo que va a ganar tu cliente
con la compra con el uso de tu producto
tu servicio para el cliente no le
interesa en tu producto en tu servicio
luego otro es lo importante no conocer
al cliente bueno me refiero no conocer
al cliente es que vamos a vender y vamos
a una empresa y hacemos una propuesta
para la compañía pero no entendemos que
quien nos compra es una persona y esa
persona tiene sus propios problemas sus
propios objetivos personales tienen su
situación y al final
es importante conocer cuál es la agenda
del cliente es y cuáles son sus
objetivos personales cuáles son sus
ambiciones profesionales cuál es la
situación en la que se encuentra dentro
de la compañía para que cuando hagan la
propuesta no la adapte pensando la
compañía porque al final te va a comprar
la persona el programa hay que entender
la agenda de esa persona otro error que
para mí es el más importante es la
metodología es decir si cuando nos
subimos a un avión los pilotos tienen un
check list que le va guiando para
asegurarse que cumplen todos los
requisitos todos los puntos necesarios
para que el viaje vaya a bordo porque
las ventas que es lo más importante
entre una organización seguramente
muchas dedica y no son las personas por
supuesto pero si no hay ingresos no hay
nómina no hay empleados entonces el tema
de las ventas es un error garrafal es
dejarlo a lo que vaya surgiendo oa la
arbitrariedad oa la improvisación y si
tenemos que tener una metodología una
hoja de ruta que nos guíe paso a paso de
forma que vayamos aplicando las
estrategias comerciales que están
aplicando otros vendedores y otras
empresas que tienen éxito y replicando
eso también vas a tener tu éxito cuando
el primer el principal fallo que todo
el primero no tiene una metodología de
ventas y eso te hace porque lo dejes a
la improvisación y algo tan importante
como las ventas no podemos dejar a la
improvisación otro error es las
objeciones como a una reunión y el
cliente nos pone una serie de objeciones
que las objeciones diferentes las
excusas es una excusa que no te quiere
comprar una objeción quiere decir que te
quiero comprar pero hay un problema
detrás que hay que resolver previamente
para poder comprar te pagan dos mientras
que haya una objeción hay una
oportunidad de negocio y qué hacemos
normalmente nos enzarzamos en una guerra
para intentar demostrarle al cliente que
tenemos razón cuando lo tenemos que
hacer es intentar identificar cuál es el
problema aunque la necesidad que tiene
el cliente por la que no te puede
comprar por tanto mientras haya
objeciones hay oportunidad de negocios
otro error importante es la falta de
seguimiento
vale decir nosotros vamos a vender a un
cliente le mandamos un email después de
la reunión le mandamos un e-mail para
hacer una reunión le llama por teléfono
y si no no responde a la primera por lo
dejamos algunos aguantan la segunda y lo
más avanzado hasta la tercera no pero si
en tres veces el cliente no te hace caso
frena
entonces eso es un error garrafal porque
su situación
en ese momento no ha visto el email se
ha traspapelado tenía un problema estaba
liado entonces la falta de seguimiento
es otro error principal por lo que
fallamos todos los los vendedores y
luego muchas veces la mejor vamos a
venderlo a un cliente y el cliente en
ese momento no nos quiere comprar
productos de servicios pero si hacemos
un seguimiento permanente de cómo va a
la empresa como que está haciendo esa
persona a través de alertas que haya en
google que nos permiten monitorizar que
lo que va pasando a esa empresa oa ese
profesional o en ese sector nos permite
que vayamos cogiendo información
interesante y mandándose la de manera
puntual y permanente para que para que
él vea que estamos ahí o sea que le
ayudamos que estamos permanentemente
ayudándole para él cuando tengo
necesidad confía en nosotros la falta es
la falta de seguimiento es otro error
importante luego no saber quién decide
si voy a una reunión habló con una
persona pero esa persona ni tiene poder
decisión ni tiene presupuesto en esta
acción de perder el tiempo cuánto es
importante saber quién decide y por qué
también porque cuando hacemos una venta
a una compañía las ventas beat uvi son
mucho más complejas
viene una media de 54 personas la toma
de decisiones pues lo tenemos que saber
quién decide para ir a cada interlocutor
es decir quién es el sponsor del
proyecto de iniciativa quién es el
decisor quién es el influenciador tienen
que trabajar bloquear la propuesta saber
quién es quién entre organización para
ir alineando los mensajes a cada uno de
ellos de forma de cuando se tome la
decisión todos vayan y decidan sobre tu
empresa y no lo dejarlo para el final
por la improvisación entonces muy
importante saber quién decide y
gestionar ese dinámico de poder que hay
la organización es luego la urgencia en
el cierre esto un error garrafal si
nosotros estamos vender porque al final
todo lo que paga las nóminas de los
empleados o porque me tengo una cuota
que marca la compañía y tengo que pagar
el colegio de los niños entonces esa
urgencia en el cierre la tenemos
nosotros pero sabemos trasladar al
cliente ni presionar al cliente porque
si no qué pasa que perdemos el cliente y
en la venta actual que no es una venta
producto céntrica sino que es una venta
más consultiva una venta más clientes
céntricas esto va de crear relación a
largo plazo cuanto si presionamos al
cliente para que nos compren el momento
que nosotros nos interese vamos a perder
ese cliente y al final como vendedores
que
importante que tenemos los clientes es
nuestro activo así que me echan de la
empresa me voy a la empresa al fin al
cliente se va a venir conmigo porque
tiene la confianza en mí entonces muchas
veces aquí nos olvidamos que es urgente
esperar y esperar el momento acompañar
al cliente quizás ahora mismo no hay que
vender el producto y dentro de un año me
lo compra
estos son los 10 principales errores
luego estos son los 8 mitos de las
ventas
un mito es que el vendedor nacen hoy no
se hace por eso muchas veces la
profesión de las ventas está
desprestigiada y no tiene el valor que
tiene porque la gente no se forma y
cualquiera se cree que va a una
formación se forma sobre el producto y
cuatro técnicas de comercial espabilados
para decirles cuál el producto a éste
alguna gestión de gestiones y un poquito
de negociación y me dedico a las ventas
para entonces por ese por ese mito está
la profesión de evaluando en la relación
de comercial luego el tema de que la
gente es a la venta para la gente
simpática todo lo contrario la mente
para gente empática así que entiende al
cliente que se pone en su lugar
identifica su necesidad de hacer un
diagnóstico y a partir de ahí le
proporciona la solución
luego para ser vendedor hay que hablar
mucho todo lo contrario para ser vendido
lo que tienes que hacer es callarse
preguntar al cliente escuchar y
diagnosticar qué necesita el cliente y a
partir de ahí hacer la propuesta que lo
que hace un médico no te dice este 20
dice lo que tiene es un resfriado
primero te te hace un diagnóstico
identificadas y de síntomas te preguntas
a partir de ahí elabora un diagnóstico y
te recomiendan pues las ventas igual
vale no va a hablar mucho sino de
escuchar luego las ventas no es para
técnicos todo lo contrario al final si
touré a un perfil técnico y ahí
desarrolla habilidades comerciales
cuando tiene una interacción con un
cliente el cliente te percibe como un
asesor como un consejero de negocios y
no como un vendedor que te quiere vender
el producto qué es lo que pasa
el perfil técnico enriquece mucho el
proceso comercial
luego los mejores vendedores son buenos
directores comerciales no tiene por qué
al final tú eres vendedor tiene una
serie de habilidades pero a la hora de
gestión el equipo comercial tienes que
desarrollar otra habilidad de otras
competencias y adquirir los
conocimientos totalmente diferentes y
por muy buen vendedor que sea
otro mito es que las ventas requieren
agresividad todo lo contrario solamente
no tiene agresividad requieren empatía
requieren instalarlas al cliente que
tiene el acompañamiento asesoramiento
confianza pero nada de agresividad esto
al final genera el resultado a corto
plazo pero a medio o largo plazo no
funciona
luego no hay una segunda oportunidad
esto también es otro mito que tenemos
que pensamos que el cliente lo cerramos
ahora y hace que entremos perdidos para
siempre no a lo largo del ciclo de vida
de ese cliente hay muchas oportunidades
comerciales para venderles en muchos
puntos de contacto cuanto quizás hoy no
sea de momento acompañas al cliente hace
un seguimiento dentro de seis meses
dentro de un año será cliente vale por
tanto eso es que no hay una segunda
oportunidad nos lleva a presionar al
cliente y nos lleva a meternos presiones
que realmente no son necesarias y luego
lo más importante es el producto no tan
importante es el cliente es uno más
importante no es producto entender al
cliente porque si entendemos al cliente
vemos sus necesidades ya buscaremos la
forma de adaptar nuestro producto para
resolver esa necesidad que tiene el
cliente
estos son los ocho mitos que yo tenía el
mundo la mente que seguramente muchos de
vosotros también tengáis cuál es la
imagen del vendedor
dais los ojos y pensáis
en un vendedor seguramente obtenga la
cabeza palabras con connotaciones
negativas para una persona que me quiere
sacar la pasta que me quiere vender su
producto a toda costa que me quiere
engañar que me está vendiendo uno es la
imagen que tenemos del vendedor que es
todo lo contrario es decir el vendedor
una persona que el vendedor profesional
en la persona que sirve una persona que
asesora una persona que acompaña que
ayuda que le encanta resolver problemas
que le encantan las personas es un
vendedor profesional para los demás son
malos profesionales pero todo por
desgracia tenemos la imagen del vendedor
de una forma negativa yo cambie esta
imagen del año 2010 estaba asesor en una
compañía que vendía empresas cárnicas en
cataluña y bueno esta empresa la haya
montado
el abuelo haya pasado el padre luego al
hijo a josé luís y es una empresa bueno
no tenía deuda había ahorrado durante la
época de bonanza ante la crisis dinero
tenía solvencia económica pero en el año
2008 como todos sabéis llega una crisis
económica brutal empiezan a caer las
ventas todos los negocios empiezan a
a caer a doble dígito las empresas
empiezan a hacer pendiente regulación de
empleo se acorta esa situación una
situación y tener tenebrosa josé luís
nos llame nos dice oye necesito un plan
para reflotar la compañía porque
llevamos dos años perdiendo todo lo que
teníamos ahorrado durante todos estos
años nos hemos quedado sin dinero que
podemos hacer italia dos opciones una
incrementar las ventas y dos reducir
costes
yo incrementa ventas no sabía reducir
costes algo porque activar la carrera y
estudiar algo de reducir costes pero
josé luís que es lo que dijo en el
consejo digo para que no se nos pagó
para que nos enseñáis y médica hay que
echar la gente se da se hace yo os pago
para que se es capaz de incrementar las
ventas yo lo que quiero es un plan para
no tienes que echar a nadie por aquí
trabaja mi familia trabaja toda la gente
del pueblo salud y quiero que busquen
una solución pero yo hay poco pude
hacerle sí que verdad que cinco años
después quedé como silvio en barcelona y
hablé con él y después luis que ha
pasado de ingeniera el puesto seis
millones de euros lo que presentará en
pesetas se han hecho sites un plan y con
ese plan que hemos conseguido sin echar
a nadie
voy a levantar las ventas
y ahí me empecé a sesionar
a ver qué es lo que había ahí empecé a
darme cuenta que las ventas eran la
mejor profesión del mundo que consiste
en servir y gracias a los vendedores a
la gente que estaba en esa compañía
fueron capaces de levantar la empresa
sin tener que echar a nadie en un
entorno super complicado cuando todo
estaba cayendo
y luego me di cuenta que lo más
importante para la empresa en la primera
línea de la cuenta de resultados es
decir las ventas todo el mundo dice no
son las personas por supuesto pero si no
hay ingreso no hay personas entonces la
función de las ventas es una función
social es y gracia que ingreso las
ventas se paga a los empleados gracias a
que hay ingresos en las ventas se paga a
los proveedores y gracias ingresos las
ventas y las empresas dan beneficios se
pagan los impuestos que luego revierten
no en la educación en la sanidad
etcétera cuando empezó a obsesionarme
todo esto empieza con un proceso de
búsqueda de investigación de aprendizaje
sobre todo el tema de la venta no es
casualidad conocí a víctor costa que él
había estudiado pues toda la parte de
ventas llevaba años analizando todo el
mundo de la venta ya tenía muchísima
experiencia y hay una embarcamos en un
proyecto
para intentar profesionalizar el mundo
las ventas y además a mí me obsesionaba
entender cuál es la clave del éxito de
las ventas es decir porque hay gente que
venden estos no tienen un entorno sin
gente que no porque hay empresas que lo
hacen mejor que otras cuál es la clave
del éxito y al final después de todo la
conclusión fue que la clave de éxito
está en la metodología de ventas esa es
la clave del éxito porque lo que ocurrió
en la empresa de josé luís
y ya para terminar quería compartir con
vosotros tres estrategias que se
pusieron en marcha la empresa josé luís
y que ahora veo que de manera
sistemática funcionan en cualquier
empresa no para impulsar las ventas la
primera es que las ventas tienen que ser
responsabilidad de toda la empresa
-sí de la persona que está en recepción
hasta el ceo de la compañía la gente hay
que entender que las ventas de
responsabilidad de todos no podemos
delegar algo tan importante solamente al
departamento comercial cuando todas las
empresas a líneas alrededor de las
ventas ocurren cosas como la ocurrió la
empresa de josé luís que el vendedor
tradicional tiene que evolucionar si
tenemos que evolucionar de ser
vendedores tradicionales productos
céntricos a convertirnos en consultores
de ventas es decir a ser un asesor a ser
un consejero de negocios y de clientes
de perciba así y luego por último que
cuando las cosas no van con las cosas
van mal el problema no son los
vendedores el problema es la metodología
de ventas por lo tanto cuando ocurren
estas tres cosas la organización ocurre
en cosas maravillosas y mágicas como las
ocurrió en la empresa de josé luís
muchas gracias